faire appel un petit peu à la
citoyenneté en chacun de nous pour
arriver à comment dire gérer la vie en
collectivité et c'est l'éternel débat
fin du contrat social quoi mais le
problème c'est qu'on est dans un monde
d'image ou en fait tout le monde
exploite tout le monde exploite les
images donc je ne sais pas à long terme
la valeur qu'on pourra accorder aux
images vu que les de plus en plus
possible d'intervenir dessus donc ça
c'est 1,5 question je pense qu'on sort
peut-être que dans cinq ans n'aura du
recul là tu pour l'instant et il me
semble qu'on est complètement en
immersion dans ce nouveau monde comme
diraient certains chanteurs connus et on
n'a pas de recul dessus et on veut tout
de suite légiférer mais en fait on a on
n'a pas réellement les moyens de le
faire parce qu'on a on n'a pas cette
distance
à mon sens qu'il faudrait pour pouvoir
statuer abbas et catégorie puisque la
loi sécurité globale savez tout
simplement justement limiter
considérablement les les libertés les
drones dans les manifestations etc etc
ces catastrophes pour la démocratie peau
et pour la liberté et la sécurité est
aussi importante que la liberté c'est
vrai mais il ya des gens qui abusent
quand même c'est pas la liberté qu'est
celle des casses et les décès le restent
chez les hommes c'est les êtres humains
qui pour les dégâts c'est pas la liberté
de monsieur de réduire la liberté et de
sécurité
sa patience pour moi à la liberté n'a
pas de prix pour ça la sécurité c'est
une autre chose
puis sa note de mort ça notre combat
qu'il faudra combattre malheureusement
les gens d'aujourd'hui fait partie d'un
ensemble
je travaille dans un centre culturel
territorial je côtoie des gens qui sont
un peu qu'on parle des choix de
politique on parle de ce qu'il faut
faire qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire
mais quand je vois des bons ce moment
qui se passe chose incroyable ce qui se
passe en france et au jour d'aujourd'hui
si c'est dommage ben oui parce qu'il ya
de la violence quand même et la violence
c'est pas la liberté
on est obligé quand même parce que sinon
on va t'on mais c'est vrai qu'on a
besoin de liberté mme on a aussi besoin
de surveiller parce qu'il ya déjà
beaucoup de violence en ce moment et
pourquoi il ya de la violence parce
qu'ils veulent tout casser
il y en a qui veulent te casser faut
quand même les empêcher
ça nous empêche aussi la liberté non
clairement je vous dis que on a besoin
plus de sécurité parce que avec déjà
d'une annaba qu'elle a déjà que la
pandémie mondiale et aussi surtout par
exemple ce qu'est manifestations souvent
souvent dire en profond beaucoup entre
tous et avec tout ce qui se passe avec
les lois avec le co vide après il ya le
confinement malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes
je ne supporte plus d'être peaufiné la
chance que j'ai que je travaille doit
milieu hospitalier j'ai un peu plus de
j'aime un peu plus de liberté je
travaille je peux
sécurité est clairement je vous dis la
vérité monsieur c'est de renforcer la
sécurité à la base c'est pas légal moi
je trouve sait pas on ne devrait pas
faire ça surtout que ce que ça va donner
un pouvoir en plus aux policiers qui
déjà ont déjà un grand très grand
pouvoir déjà pas techniquement wadja moi
je sais pas c'est pas là il ya deux
possibilités
après il faudrait voir s'il n'y a pas
d'autres moyens plus vos intérêts plus
qui sont en accord avec la liberté des
gens le droit de manifester est un droit
et pourquoi surveiller les gens quand un
individu se comporte normalement ils
n'apprennent rien du tout nous sommes
bien d'accord
voilà mon raisonnement voilà la façon de
voir maintenant en faire un débat
politique et attiser les le problème des
libertés avant tout ce qui serait très
intéressant c'est que notre société se
remettent en cause elle-même les
citoyens par eux-mêmes de telle sorte
que l'on respecte les valeurs